all right folks
this is the big one we've looked at all
kinds of plays in this series
outplays aces sneaky plays yolo plays
but we've never looked at them all
together this week we are bringing you
the list that we've somehow
never done before the top 10 greatest
esports plays
of all time but before we get into that
i want to tell you that this week's
video is brought to you by razer
and their brand new razer huntsman mini
gaming keyboard
this is a 60 gaming keyboard with
razer's optical switches
it's portable it's streamlined and it
actuates at
lightning speed alright now that you
know all that here are the top 10
esports plays
of all time
kicking off our list at number 10 is a
place so iconic it added a whole word
to the esports dictionary
in a melee's double match at scsa west
coast circuit silent spectrum tank
pulled off an unavoidable
zero to death combo that was undoubtedly
hype
but the reaction from the casters was
even better combo
it's easy to see why the clip went viral
spreading the gospel of wombo to more
than 17.5
million people before that moment wombo
combo meant
team combos fox combos and pizza
apparently
but after this play went viral it meant
any unavoidable combo of abilities in
any game that was insane that was such a
great wombo combo from the side of g-rex
taking the number nine spot on our list
is a play that not only won ti-3
it brought alliance back from the brink
puck's dream coil ability
leashes enemy heroes forcing them to
stay near it or take
more damage and get stunned s4 showed
earlier in the match that he was willing
to get cheeky with dream coils and delay
his opponents on na'vi who were trying
to return to base
and it worked letting alliance do a ton
of damage to the radiant structures but
when s4 landed a coil against both
dendy and puppy it literally won the
game for alliance
as both funic and hovost were forced to
stand their ground
and die alone in defense of their base
it's not enough
he's not going to be back in the face
he's got bkb but no boots of travel oh
[Music]
now if they go over the throne it could
be game
buttocks down alliance are doing it
they need a little more of those to fall
down
in jeopardy there's a glimpse it's going
to be their last stand
they want to do it they're going to do
it
alliance wins they win t-i-3
coming in at number eight is a play that
looks incredible
but only gets better once you realize
what's actually happening
rocket league has a rule that at the end
of regulation time the game doesn't
actually
end until the ball touches the ground
and that simple rule
brought rocket league fans a moment
they'll never forget
ladies and gentlemen my voice is gone
but my spirit is high we have overtime
at the rlcs season 5 finals nrg
we're down with only seconds left to
play
in a desperate attempt to force overtime
they kept the ball airborne long enough
for justin to make an incredible shot
and for rocket league to get its most
memorable call
ever need this immediately they've got
to kick them in their favor
kayla tries to clear it is almost
damaged as it hits the floor
by the panda puts it the long way and
it's almost there
justin keeps it alive there bounces
[Applause]
when your name becomes synonymous with a
play you know that you've left your mark
on esports
which is why xpeke's backdoor is taking
the number 7 spot on our list
crazy crazy games between these teams
yeah unexpected a hero in the end
and iem kind of beats in 2013 expected
was up against
sk gaming and his greatest rival ocelot
the group stage game was important both
teams were one and one and
needed a win to advance nearly an hour
into the game
both teams bases were pretty damaged but
things were still
close xpeke playing kassadin sensed an
opportunity and the rest was pure
adrenaline they've got two individuals
down and they're just gonna pile
straight up towards those super minions
in the face you can see there's coming
in that package definitely up towards
the nexus
kevin is going to be out of the game
he's trying to do it but meanwhile we're
in the base yellow stars trying to
defend them in the base
he's trying to take the nexus down is
anyone gonna have to deal with this one
catches him with another
[Applause]
as expected single-handedly sealed his
team's win he made a history
and now whenever a backdoor looks
possible fans
everywhere honor his legacy with calls
of
expec the minions are on the nexus
he does go down but the minions are
gonna take it he's got it
i do not believe what broken just did
he's just done a peck on pancakes
a play that perfectly captures a
player's attitude towards the game
while also clutching out a round is
doubly sweet
and simple's falling off at esl one
cologne has the swagger you'd expect
from the ukrainian sniper
simple i don't know man if he just comes
in with that as though he's gone
he didn't even he had we had one bite on
his mouth
he had one button there was no zoom
force to try to clutch out 1v2
and holding the off simple decided that
actually he was just too
good to use a scope see if double
smoke's in the same place they're simple
just jumping casually to the side
are you serious what is that you can't
do that simple that's not allowed this
is not mpl this is a major
valve was impressed too immortalizing
the play in a piece of graffiti
the next time you're on cash and you see
this remember the moment that simple
made liquid fans
everywhere believe that horses can fly
or at least fall
when you're on the biggest stage in
esports it can be easy to lose your cool
when you're faced with an
incredible engage from your opponent it
takes nerves of steel to stay calm and
play your way out of it
and at the international 2 na'vi showed
the world exactly
what that looks like it's light of
heaven with this bkb
they turn it around i don't even know
how they're gonna do it
standing ovation from the crowd their
opponents invictus gaming set up for a
huge team fight using naga sirens alt
and dark sears vacuum
but between juggernaut's magic community
and the black king bar that enigma was
holding
na'vi had the tools to fight back navi's
about to be caught
oh there's the sleep the sir he catches
everyone oh this could be a total
disaster
thank you man ravaged on everyone the
black hole is well flight abandoned
turns it around ravaged
puppy talked about the naga counter it's
line of heaven
what does bkb they turn it around i
don't even know how they're gonna do it
standing ovation from the crowd the last
after the black hole from light of
heaven hovos blade fury and dendi's
stolen ravage
absolutely destroyed ig's chances of
winning a fight that they chose
when you smack an opponent down like
this they just
call it the play
coming in at number four is a play that
didn't just win a game
it completely changed the meta it's
boxers bunker rush the play that changed
starcraft forever
when boxer used his crisp micro to
unleash the bunker rush on yellow in the
2004 ever
osl semifinals it ended the best of five
in a 30 minute
sweep boxer had spent countless hours
perfecting the strategy and
yellow had no answers
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
taking the number three spot on our list
is cs go's play of the decade
an ace that still leaves us speechless
to this
day i think i just broke my chair i
might need a new one
yep i think i actually did just break my
chair hold on let me get into it csgo is
all about managing your economy so you
can buy the best weapons as
often as possible but one gun is the
great equalizer
with its ability to kill off of one
headshot and an affordable 700 price tag
the desert eagle is always ready to make
things happen
and in cs go no deagle play is more
iconic than happy's rampage at dreamhack
open london 2015.
his fellow frenchman on team envy were
up round on tsm in the grand finals
and we're hoping to keep that lead with
one of their trademark aggressive force
buys
the tsm they're scared about this
they're re they aren't rushing this time
around they're taking their sweet time
hoping
to catch somebody peak on envy's side
and well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan dig
oh and another one oh the third
happy he could get another one here too
debris is like sweating bullets he's
gonna get the quad killing the ace
what is this
in the end happy's teammates could have
just saved their money because he had
enough heat
for everyone i think i just broke my
chair i might need a new one
yep i think i actually did just break my
chair hold on let me get into it
a worthy sacrifice a chair for a round
that's going to go down in history
without a doubt here
our runner-up is league of legends
greatest 1v1
faker versus ryu do you have just faker
nightmares you wake up in a cold sweat
you're like
faker's behind me i know right let's
face it dominant
1v1 outplays are pure hype but when you
have an incredible call to go along with
it and the opponent's reaction is caught
on camera
you're approaching the perfect storm
even better though is the fact that
because of the weird rule set
both faker and ryu are playing the same
champion something that's just
impossible today like even though i only
have a bat on the floor i think he's in
the bed oh baker may be in trouble or
death mark
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the class look at the moves
thank her what was that sure maybe the
1v1 duel itself wasn't important to the
outcome of the game but
sometimes that's even more of a flex
faker decided to make sure that ryu
understood his place even as ryu's team
lost
baker with a huge i play the qss i
can't take my thoughts i
you thought we could get through this
list without including this one you were
wrong
but you have to admit it's a classy play
i mean look at the cleanse oh look at
the class look at the moves look at the
bones
just look at it finger what was that
and finally taking the number one spot
on our list
is evo moment 37.
folks there are no plays more important
to competitive gaming than this one
its incredible impact on the gaming
landscape can not
be denied at evo 2004 a faded
confrontation took place between justin
wong and daigo umehara in straight
fighter 3
third strike with daigo sitting on a
sliver of health
justin tried to chip him out with
chun-li's super betting that the beast
couldn't
parry every hit
[Applause]
though justin bet incorrectly we're glad
he did
because for literally millions of people
this clip was their first introduction
to what an
incredible esports play could look like
and what an event with a
passionate crowd could really feel like
and before any of you hop into the
comments and talk about how you did this
in training mode
consider this could you do it with that
crowd behind you
with the round on the line with justin
wong sitting next to you and mashing
furiously to screw up your timing in
2004
yeah probably not
[Applause]
all right folks that's our list and no
we didn't include the olaf boost or the
jumping off
if you think we should have or if
there's another play you think we should
have put on this list
then make sure to let us know in the
comments below also don't forget to like
the video
sub to the channel and head over to
twitch.tv for esports and follow us
there so you never miss a stream
thanks so much for watching and we'll
see you next time alright so obviously
this video is brought to you by razer
but i want to be clear that they didn't
pay me to say this part
which is that i was using this thing a
little bit just to sort of get a sense
of how good it is and it is actually a
great keyboard and it's got these
optical switches and i can tell they're
good
because they make the most satisfying
clicking sound i've ever heard
this is probably going to sound insane
when i put up to the mic but you have to
understand
this right here what you're about to
hear this is what peak gaming
performance sounds like
it sounds so good